le débat sur la dépénalisation des
drogues douces après la révélation d'un
rapport officiel sur les dangers
comparer de l'alcool du cannabis mais
aussi de drogues plus dures comme la
cocaïne ou l'héroïne
c'est un débat forcément polémique qui
s'engagent car il y entre des arguments
scientifiques mais aussi politique et de
principe
valérie gas g/j marine ou contre la
dépénalisation du cannabis
le débat ressurgit aussi régulièrement
que la fumée d'une cigarette
ces dernières années une série de
rapports officiels sont venus
l'alimenter il eut d'abord en 94 celui
du comité national d'éthique déjà les
sages estimait que certaines drogues
licites comme le tabac ou l'alcool était
aussi dangereux sinon plus que le
cannabis y deux mois plus tard une
commission présidée par le professeur
henrion se prononcer en faveur d'une
dépénalisation de l'usagé du cannabis
hier un nouveau travail d'experts était
publié il précise qu aucune drogue est
inoffensive mais classe le cannabis
parmi les moins nocives
tous ces rapports permettent de poser la
question de la dépénalisation mais à
l'exception des verts la classe
politique s'y refuse
si on légalisait le cannabis je pense
que c'est le verrou de la prohibition ça
oblige à le pouvoir à la déchire d'une
façon beaucoup plus intelligente parader
dans l'équipe aux véritables problèmes
sanitaires comme l'héroïne comme le
crack ou comme l'ecstasy et comme ils
veulent pas se poser ces questions parce
qu'effectivement sur les questions
difficiles à résoudre exactement d'un
véritable débat et le travail des
vaincus les politiques savent aussi que
leur électorat est réticent le dernier
sondage publié en juillet dernier révèle
que 6 14% des français ont déjà fumé du
haschisch 58% sont hostiles à la
distinction drogues dures drogues douces
et 64 % refusent la dépénalisation et
pourtant de nombreux spécialistes
pensent qu'il faut réviser la loi
actuelle loge ans c'est si tu changé de
voie pour qu'on ne puisse plus les
il s'agit de toi gates auxi koeman mais
maintenir l'interdît est très important
parce que sinon comment ça vous ans on
commence à voir si justement ce sont les
simples usagers où les toxicomanes en
france près de deux millions de
personnes fument régulièrement du
cannabis
à l'heure actuelle ils sont tous des
hors la loi